at indonesia's main airport a highly
anticipated delivery has arrived
inside this container are 1.2 million
doses of the covert 19 vaccine from
china
more will come next month and later the
raw materials to allow indonesia to
manufacture millions of doses itself
scientific considerations and the final
results of the clinical trials will
determine
when the covert 19 vaccinations can be
carried out
the vaccines won't be used until they're
given clearance by the indonesian food
and drug authority
we're still waiting for the data
relating to safety and efficiency
we need three months of data to check
the blood test
in tangarang not far from the capital
hospital workers are preparing
pharmaceutical refrigerators
the synovac vaccine needs to be stored
between two to eight degrees
which is a common temperature
requirement for many vaccines
indonesia's government has also
pre-ordered 100 million
doses of the vaccine developed by oxford
astrazeneca
which has the same temperature
requirements
we are ready to receive to store and
distribute in accordance to the
standards set by the national
agency of drug and food control but not
everyone shares this confidence
far from the capital on the island of
flores health officials in sikka
are concerned about their lack of
resources
[Music]
the problem we face now even for regular
vaccines
is that the electricity cuts out often
thousands of remote communities around
the country don't have reliable power
health workers also say they don't have
enough cold storage units
if the coronavirus vaccine comes here we
can't store it yet
i hope we can have a bigger cool room so
we can store vaccines for the whole area
when needed
indonesia with its tropical climate and
thousands of remote communities
is not alone in facing issues with cold
chain logistics
the vaccines developed by american
pharmaceuticals corporations
pfizer and moderna require ultra cold
storage
at sub-zero temperatures because of that
requirement
it may not be a feasible option for some
countries
it will be very helpful if the
temperature is not too low for the
requirements
so for the minus storage and
distribution
it will have a big challenge for the
country and for the province
manufacturing and procuring the vaccine
is only part of the problem
in the fight against covert 19. for many
countries the bigger challenge
is managing the logistics jessica
washington al jazeera jakarta